what is up everybody it's animak here
for
anime uproar and today i will be
breaking down the latest developments in
black clover including yami finally
returning to the battlefield after so
long in order to save osta and knocked
lives we also learned that lucifero
doesn't actually wield any authority
over the emo devil and mario leona is
apparently becoming a logia user so
let's get into it you guys know the
drill if you enjoy our black clover
videos and you want us to keep it going
leave a quick like and comment it only
takes a second but it really helps with
the youtube algorithm and if you're new
here or maybe you watch the channel but
you just haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a quick favor and
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications finally this video
will of course contain black clover
manga spoilers so please proceed with
caution you have been warned now in the
previous chapter tabata pulled off the
biggest troll of all time and i can't
freaking believe that some people
actually fell for it tabata had dark
lord seke pretend that he was scared of
lucifero and that he just wanted to run
away from the battlefield
what an absolutely ridiculous concept
tabata even had seki pretend to be in
disbelief about why people like yuno and
mero leona would put their lives at risk
to fight someone as overpowered as
lucifero and then sekke even pretends to
ask mimosa to escape the battlefield all
of this is just part of sekei's
multi-dimensional master plan of course
a plan that people without at least two
phds can't even begin to understand so
to be honest there is no point of me
trying to explain it here that said his
majesty lord sekke does express his
respect for asta who despite being
nearly dead forces himself to stand up
once again as yuno and mera leona are
facing off against lucifero asta drags
his sword and himself forward one step
at a time vowing to help despite his
terrible condition sekei then sheds a
single small manly tear a tear of
respect for asta as a fellow warrior and
fellow protagonist sekhei really was the
shining star of chapter 320 although
asta was a close second in the latest
chapter noct shows up in his armored
form and tells asta that he is in no
condition to fight so he should not be
on the battlefield at the same time
though knock knows that lucifero can't
be defeated without anti-magic so even
though asta is in no condition to fight
he also pretty much has to be on the
battlefield knocked decides that if
foster has to be on the battlefield then
he will be there right by his side and
he will protect asta until the time
comes for anti-magic to play its part
meanwhile yuno and mario leona are still
going all out in battle against lucifero
but none of their attacks have been
effective at the same time they have to
be extremely careful because even a
single attack from lucifero could kill
them on the spot now even though
lucifero isn't really in any real danger
here since yuno and merlona can't seem
to actually hurt him the devil is
getting annoyed by this whole situation
he knows that he has to eliminate asta
as soon as possible so he doesn't have
to deal with anti-magic later anti-magic
could turn out to be a problem for him
so he wants to eliminate that potential
threat as soon as possible so under
these circumstances lucifero ends up
doing something unexpected he calls out
to the emo devil whose name is revealed
to be adramelech lucifero screams at
adramelech to deal with yuno and mario
leona so that he can take care of asta
but the emo devil responds with a
hilarious
i'd rather not lucifero then proceeds to
call him a bastard but adramelech just
kind of shrugs it off and says that
watching lucifera fight is just too much
fun this is funny but it's also a very
important exchange i think that a lot of
us just kind of assume that because
lucifero is one of the strongest devils
and because he is sometimes referred to
as the king of devils that other devils
have to follow his orders but clearly
that is not the case since the emo devil
doesn't even think twice before directly
disobeying lucifero clearly the
hierarchy of the underworld is more
complicated than we thought like yeah we
know that liba hates lucifero but there
is a very specific reason for that and
we also know that makikula was doing
things behind his back but that's very
different from so fragrantly disobeying
him right to his face
the fact that adramelech is able to
speak to lucifero this way means that he
clearly isn't afraid of any retaliation
so could the emo devil be a lot stronger
than we realize and could there be some
sort of devil civil war brewing in the
future with other devils potentially
joining the good guys like liba did in
order to take down the bad devils or did
adramelech disobey lucifero because he
is waiting for orders from his real
master the dark lord seki let me know
what you guys think about this crazy
turn of events down in the comments
below the emo devil's brazen dismissal
of lucifero definitely took me by
surprise and this single brief moment
could have serious consequences on the
rest of the story as mera leona
continues to give it her all in the
fight against lucifero she suddenly
realizes that her body is no longer
holding its shape properly the emo devil
then reveals that she has gotten too
close to mana which is something that
humans are not supposed to do
we don't get an exact explanation but
the implication here is that mero
leona's body may be giving out and
disintegrating because she pushed
herself too far and merged too closely
with mana in an attempt to gain more
power however i refuse to believe that
mero leona is our badass waifu queen and
i'm sure that she's just becoming a
logia user okay that's it okay that's
all while lucifero continues chasing and
fighting marijuana and you know knocked
uses a new form called devil union
connie's ex ekus to summon a massive
two-headed beast which then attacks
lucifero the monster grabs one of
lucifer's arms in each of its two mouths
and while lucifero is restrained asta
attempts to cut him down using yami's
katana to me it looks like noctis is
actually using shadow magic to help us
to move at this point i'm not 100 sure
on that but ost is just so exhausted and
injured that i wouldn't be surprised
this was definitely a good plan by knox
and asta but unfortunately lucifero is
able to break free before asta can do
anything and in fact he is happy to see
asta because now he has a chance to kill
him as lucifero launches an attack on
asta noctis forced to protect asta with
his own body the attack is so brutal
that its smash is knocked right out of
his devil union mode knocked truly
believes that he has reached his end and
he expects that he will be seeing his
brother morgan very soon but as noct
prepares to apologize to his brother in
the afterlife yami suddenly shows up and
blocks lucifero's punch with a new
katana that appears to be made from
world tree magic this is just my guess
of course but it would make sense
because if william has regained
consciousness then he may have been the
one who healed the ami in the first
place and then created this new weapon
for him and in this epic and
long-awaited moment as yami finally
enters the battle after all this time
the chapter comes to an end because of
course
but even though waiting for the next
chapter is going to be hard because i
want to see ami in action so badly i am
super excited that he is finally back in
the game it looks like both yami and
william could be taking over the battle
for a while and if so then they will
likely combine dark magic and world tree
magic to create some truly incredible
combo moves lucifero better be ready
because our boy is back and also william
probably williams all right i guess
man this chapter had a lot going on in
just a few pages we had the actual fight
against lucifero but we also had the
adramelech gamer moment we had the
ominous marijuana development knocked
almost died then yami shows up and all
of that was in just one chapter
absolutely insane what did you guys
think of this chapter is marilona really
dying or is her power just evolving with
all the memes about no one dying in
black clover i would be extremely pissed
if the one important character who does
end up dying is a top tier badass waifu
like merolona tabata please just hear me
out leave vanessa and marilona alone and
with the other guys hey it's your call
you're the author by the way how do you
think that yami recovered was it william
as i'm speculating that it was and if so
what happens next can william also help
asta recover even though mimosa couldn't
can dark magic world tree magic and
anti-magic work together to actually
take lucifero down and what about the
emo devil adramelech is he going to do
something important sometime soon or is
he just gonna sit back and watch like he
has been doing all this time don't
forget to share your thoughts on all
these crazy twists and turns down in the
comments below if you guys enjoyed this
video and you want to see more in the
future you know what to do just leave a
quick like and comment it only takes a
second but it really helps and if you
want a completely free way to directly
support this channel in a way that
matters just click that subscribe button
hit the bell and then select the option
that says all it might sound like just a
little thing but it actually helps me
out a lot on youtube you can also hit me
up on twitter and instagram at
animeopror i want to give a quick thank
you to all of our anime uproar patrons
for making videos like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma and
kyle salisbury these guys are absolute
mad lads and disciples of lord twego
himself and i can't forget all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above all other clans including ingrata
algital pate heffa the red haired fox
hinokamian water the toasted cheek corey
mcgowan the spike lonely the car dylan
isidore spidey life tanel tungsten
tarkis big buddhist jeremy cummings and
che whitley finally thank you also to
our pro hero tier patrons including the
one and only gilgamesh steelers on hell
cruise very gucci alicia octor bonnie
parks joanne garcia fat boy games kaido
might be a duck jessica rabbit jeremy
phillips alivania temple king matthew
and demetrius water if you guys enjoy
our videos and you feel that they
provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos along with
these amazing people oh and if you don't
have a patreon account becoming a
youtube channel member gives you the
same perks as always thank you guys so
much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you